for many people sleep disruptions are a
serious side effect of this pandemic
more than half of americans in a recent
survey reported
an increase in sleep problems since this
pandemic started
clinical psychologist and sleep
specialist yup he's a sleep specialist
we like that hi michael bruce
joins us to discuss michael you remember
in the very beginning this pandemic
changed everything upside down in the
beginning people couldn't even remember
what day of the week it was everything
all seemed to run together
so why are we seeing an increase in
sleep problems now
you know it's it's interesting so first
of all always happy to see you gail
but uh it's interesting to see what's
going on these days one of the things we
know now
is people are off schedule quite a bit
since the pandemic not having to
go to work on time and things like that
and that's really shifted a lot of
people's circadian rhythms or their
internal sleep schedule
and made it extremely difficult the
other big thing is people aren't
moving a lot you know sleep is recovery
and if we want to
recover we have to recover from
something and if we're not moving around
a lot that could be a problem as well
also we've seen a dramatic increase in
both caffeine consumption
as well as alcohol consumption both of
which have dramatic effects
on our sleep so it's not particularly
surprising that we're seeing some sleep
difficulties
but the good news is we know what those
difficulties are and we have some ideas
on how to fix them
so so well what should we do michael
because i mean i know i tried melatonin
the other day
didn't work didn't help what can we do
so first of all let's talk about
melatonin for a quick second so
melatonin is not a sleeping pill it's
actually something that changes your
circadian rhythms
great for jet lag but not necessarily
for what we're talking about here
one of the first things i tell people to
do is stick to a
solid sleep schedule if you don't know
what a good sleep schedule is for you
go to chronoquiz.com and you can learn
exactly what your sleep schedule needs
to be
the second thing is be active you know
what 20 minutes a day you can walk
around
get outside get some sunshine it's
definitely going to help you out
another thing is stopping caffeine by 2
pm
a lot of people say oh my gosh i don't
know if i can handle that you really
want to slow down your caffeine by two
because it's got a
six to eight hour half life and could be
affecting you later on
and then finally with alcohol there's a
really big difference between going to
sleep and
passing out right we want to avoid the
passing out so
stop alcohol about three hours before
bed if you follow these four rules i can
almost
guarantee you you're going to snap your
sleep right back into shape all right
that's all good advice michael bruce
thank you so much